hey 42 here history is full of monsters
adolf hitler joseph stalin and the bloke
who invented squirty cheese
if it's your life goal to be the world's
biggest see you next tuesday
there's some pretty stiff competition so
when you earn yourself the epithet
the wickedest man in the world you know
you've been
a really naughty boy but the man who did
have that nickname
alastair crowley never cared too much
about public opinion
the year was 1875 and queen victoria had
wedged her ample frame
firmly onto the english throne when like
many of history's greatest villains
crowley was born in a rather smart
townhouse in royal lemington spa
considering the controversy he would
caught throughout most of his adult life
crowley seems to have been a
surprisingly normal kid
having said that in a nice bit of
foreshadowing it said his mother called
him
the beast a nickname he would adopt in
later life
when he started non-ironically referring
to himself as
the great beast 666 which
sounds like the playstation network
username of a sexually frustrated
teenager to me
but i think people were quite impressed
at the time
crowley's father died of tongue cancer
when little alastair was just 11 years
old
and it was this tragic event that set
him on the path to infamy
in the space of just a few short years
the nice little boy from lemmington spa
had denounced his religious beliefs
started causing trouble at school
taken up smoking and begun sleeping with
prostitutes
one of whom was generous enough to give
him gonorrhea along with the other
services he paid for
it was to be the first of an impressive
collection of stds
crowley would accumulate in his lifetime
despite having become something of a
rebel crowley was an excellent student
and at the age of 20 he left home to
study at cambridge university
as it is for many young people uni was a
chance for crowley to experiment
he switched courses from philosophy to
english literature
became an accomplished mountaineer and
developed into such a strong
chess player he briefly considered going
pro
he also conducted experiments of the
sexual variety
taking many partners of both sexes and
adding
syphilis to his budding std collection
sex
especially if the weird variety would
play a big part in the occultist
activities for which he would one day
become very famous but we'll get to all
that later
he was also a keen poet a habit he kept
up his entire life
but his poems were shall we say
a little unusual in his final year at
cambridge he published a collection
about
how can i put this without getting
demonetised
his um solo adventures
and just in case my meaning isn't clear
enough
i can tell you he gave his new book the
rather charming title
white stains which sounds pretty risque
even today so you can imagine how people
reacted in 1898
not well in the end he was forced to
publish the collection abroad for fears
of persecution at home
ultimately it seems crowley had little
time left over for
trivial things like studying and he left
university without obtaining a degree
the good news was that he'd finally
figured out what he wanted to do with
his life
alistar crowley was going to dedicate
himself to the occult
with the aim of becoming the world's
most
powerful magus as you do
to that end he became a member of the
hermetic order of the golden dawn
a secret society with an interest in the
occult
metaphysics and the paranormal the order
had been founded by a couple of
freemasons 10 years prior and they were
known to spend their time studying
astrology geomancy and tarot cards
at this point you might be picturing
some kind of stereotypical secret
society
full of aging white men dressed up in
silly costumes
and taking part in arcane rituals
but in this case you'd be correct
absolutely 100
correct but this was a different time
and grown men playing it wizards didn't
come with quite the same stigma it does
today
as a result the hermetic order of the
golden dawn
counted some important and celebrated
individuals amongst its number
including bram stoker he just published
his seminal novel dracula
when crowley joined the order in 1898
irish poet w b yates and sir arthur
conan doyle
creator of sherlock holmes for the first
time in his life crowley was truly in
his element
he took to his magic studies like
hermione granger on amphetamines
demonstrating the kind of devotion he'd
never brought to bear at cambridge
and he delighted in being around
like-minded individuals
well i say like-minded
whilst the golden dawn was everything
crowley had been looking for
the order did not unfortunately
feel quite the same way about crowley
many of the higher-ups took their
calling
as wizards and magi very seriously
and they believed true power could only
be obtained by those who abstained
from drink drugs and sex
unfortunately drink drugs and sex were
the three pillars
upon which crowley based his entire
existence
so clashes were inevitable it's rumored
he fell
out with yates and other important
members of the order
and when he was passed over for
promotion to the group's inner circle
things went south quickly instead of
taking this set back like a good little
wizard crowley went rogue
attempting to seize control of one of
the golden dawn's london temples
known as the vault of the adepts well i
say temple it turns out the vault of the
adepts
bears a striking resemblance to your
standard london terraced house
but i guess number 36 blythe road
didn't sound quite mystical enough
unsurprisingly this little stunt spells
the end of crowley's career
with the hermetic order of the golden
dawn but
his determination to become a great and
powerful wizard
had not diminished if anything getting
the boot had lit a fire under his arse
he began scouring the globe for ancient
wisdom
working his way through mexico the usa
india japan china hong kong
paris canada and algeria what it seems
it was in
egypt where he finally found what he was
looking for
or should i say what he was looking for
found him
crowley had recently gotten married and
the happy couple chose cairo for their
honeymoon
once safely in the honeymoon suite
crowley turns to his new bride and gave
her a couple of suggestive eyebrow
razors
she knew exactly what he wanted to do
turn the room into a makeshift temple
and start invoking egyptian deities
ever the enigma his honeymoon turned out
to be the only time
crowley didn't have sex on the brain
though the couple must have eventually
gotten around to it because they had
their first child the following year
we know crowley was happy to become a
father because
as a thank you to his wife for making it
all possible
he wrote her a charming collection of
pornographic poetry
because highbrow porn is exactly what
you need when you just squeezed a baby
out of your vagina
anyway after some vigorous passionate
and no doubt sweaty deity invoking
in cairo a spirit called aiwas appeared
and started whispering in crowley's ear
apparently
i was as it turned out was a messenger
of the god horus
and it seems he had an awful lot to say
for himself because once he started
talking
he didn't shut up for three days
straight
and this was no idol chit chat about the
weather
or the frankly scandalous price of
diesel when the three days were up
the messenger of the gods had dictated
an entire book which was to become the
foundational text
of a new religion known as felomer the
text which came to be known as the book
of the law
detailed how humanity was about to enter
a new era
and conveniently enough it named crowley
as a prophet it also outlined one
supreme philosophy
do what thou will shall be the whole of
the law
and this maxim became the cornerstone of
felimer
according to crowley life was all about
the pursuit of each person's will
regardless of popular opinion law
or conventional ethics in other words
look after yourself and screw everyone
else
and he certainly seems to have practiced
what he preached
for example the following year he made
an ill-fated attempt
to scale kachenjunga the world's third
highest mountain that was at the time
unclimbed and widely considered the most
dangerous peak on earth
during the expedition crowley's fellow
mountaineers eventually got sick of him
being
reckless weird and a bit of a dick
and they started making their own way
back down the mountain as night fell
this went against crowley's advice and
sure enough
some of them were subsequently killed in
an avalanche
but rather than show concern for his
fellow mountaineers
or even settling for a simple i told you
so
crowley is reported to have completely
ignored
the survivor's cries for help in favor
of chilling out in his tent
what a guy by 1920 crowley was making
plans to move to the italian island of
sicily
to establish a new headquarters for his
religion
it would become known as the abbey of
phelama and
a lot of freaky things went on there
though almost all of them
involved sex and drugs in one form or
another
you see crowley was a firm believer in
something he called
sex magic which he spelt with a k
to make sure nobody mixed it up with the
boring gold pg-13 magic you get at
children's parties
sex magic is an extremely complicated
belief system
that requires many years of study to
even begin to understand
and a lifetime to master but i think
i've managed to figure out the gist
it's a flimsy excuse to convince people
to have sex with you
basically if crowley thought you were
hot there was a good chance
eyewass messenger of horus was about to
appear in a drug-filled vision
to demand an immediate orgy as
ridiculous as this premise was
it seems crowley truly was a master of
convincing
men women and according to some rumors
animals that his wand really was
magical because he practiced this brand
of
sex magic all over the world and with
countless partners
and things as for the drugs
crowley is said to have done so much
cocaine at his abbey
his naval cavity began to erode it's
actually quite surprising he found the
time considering how much heroin he was
doing
he was also rather partial to a bit of
opium he was a big fan of hashish as an
a2 mysticism
and was known to offer punch spiked with
peyote
at get-togethers with his followers just
to make sure
everyone thought a bunch of weird occult
stuff had happened
even though all they'd been doing was
sitting on the sofa giggling
anyway it was all going swimmingly at
the abbey until 1923
when one of crowley's followers died
after drinking water from a polluted
stream
the man's wife immediately returned to
london where she sold her story to the
press
as well as the unfortunate death of her
husband
she spoke of terrible conditions at the
abbey of the phelamites
which sounded quite grand but was
actually a small cottage covered in
animal feces
she told her strange rituals being
performed in the dead of night
she also confessed she'd been forced to
drink the blood of a sacrificed cat
on crowley's orders and that she and
other felomer acolytes
were required to cut themselves of razor
blades
every time they used the pronoun i and
you thought being careful with which
pronouns you used was a 21st century
thing
the british press had a field day and it
was here that crowley was branded
with the title that will come to define
him for the rest of his days
the wickedest man in the world
the negative press was so bad that
mussolini the power in italy at the time
had crowley forcibly deported you know
you're having a public relations crisis
where mussolini doesn't want anything to
do with you
mind you this wouldn't be the only time
crowley was thrown out of her country
he'd already been forced to leave india
after shooting
two muggers and in later life he'd be
told to leave france
on account of his reputation for
debauchery and occultism
so yeah he was about as popular in the
queue for immigration as covid
but the rough ride crowley got in the
british press didn't only stem from
stories of death and depravity at the
abbey of felimer
nor from the fact he was bisexual
homosexuality was illegal at the time
or his drug use no what really got
crowley in the bad books
was his support for the germans during
the first world war
when he regularly wrote for pro-german
propagandist publications like the
fatherland
as you can probably imagine he was
vilified back home in blighty
but as it turned out crowley was
actually one of the good guys
at least in this case you see he'd
infiltrated
german operations so he could actively
work against them
and his overblown hyperbolic rants in
the fatherland were carefully designed
to make the publication a laughingstock
alastair crowley grand magus
and dark wizard had also been working as
a double agent for the british
intelligence service in his spare time
perhaps considering all the crap he took
from the first world war
by the time the second world war broke
out crowley had decided to nail his
colours firmly to the mast
he branded hitler a black magician and
wrote to the naval intelligence division
offering his services in the fight
against the nazis
on this occasion they declined but
crowley maintained close ties with a
variety of writers in the intelligence
community
including dennis wheatley roald dahl and
ian fleming
he must have had quite an impression on
ian fleming in particular
as the celebrated writer not only based
the james bond villain le chief on
crowley
but crowley was also fleming's first
choice to interrogate a cult obsessed
nazi
rudolf hess when he was captured in
scotland despite not having much to do
during the second world war
crowley claims to have made his mark by
coming up with the v for victory sign
used by winston churchill believing it
would be
a powerful magical symbol to counteract
the swastika
whether or not he anticipated his modern
day usage a handy way to say
f you when someone cuts you up on the
motorway is unknown
crowley eventually died in 1947
age 72 in poverty obscurity and
no doubt significantly less sexually
active than he was in his prime
after all there can't be too many women
or men
who are turned on by the heroin addicted
skeleton look
despite his controversial life crowley's
influence on occultism
and pop culture can't be overstated his
pet religion
felimer is still very much alive today
and its followers believe crowley to
have been a great prophet
just as iwas claimed back in egypt
elrond hubbard was once a dedicated
phelomite
and it's probably no coincidence he
ended up following in his mentor's
footsteps
in inventing sorry i mean discovering
his
own religion scientology but it's
perhaps in the world of music that
crowley is most fondly remembered which
probably shouldn't come as a surprise
after all he may have been a black
magician and an occultist
but on a steady diet of sex drugs and
well more sex and drugs he truly lived
like a rock star
he became an icon for the hippie
movement in the 60s and 70s
and he was name checked in the work of
some of the biggest bands in history his
mug shot made the cut on what might be
the most famous album cover of all time
the beatles sergeant pepper's lonely
article abandoned
and he cropped up in songs by the likes
of led zeppelin
david bowie ozzy osbourne and the red
hot chili peppers
zeppelin's robert plant was so obsessed
with crowley
he even bought his old house whatever
crowley got up to during his highly
unconventional life
he not only had an indirect influence on
those more
anti-authoritarian parts of pop culture
the beats poets rock and roll and punk
but also on things like sexual
liberation he's often accused of sexism
of course between penning poem poems
and telling women they had to sleep with
him because his made-up god said so
he wasn't exactly a feminist but
on the other hand he also advocated
complete sexual freedom for both men and
women
not only that but he argued homosexual
and
bisexual people should not be ashamed or
afraid of who they were
and that they shouldn't have to violate
their own true nature
due to public opinion for that
and many other reasons he was very much
ahead of his time crowley once said
certain actions produce certain results
and no matter what you might think about
him his actions produced results which
have shaped our world
in a variety of ways in 2002 he was even
voted
number 73 in the bbc's list
of a hundred greatest britons which
surely would have enraged the tabloids
who gave him such a hard time during his
life
so was aleister crowley truly wicked
well kind of but as is often the case
the truth is a bit more complicated than
that
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you